- [announcer] If you've
been itching for a vacation,
you're not alone.
Summer holiday travel has
surged to levels not seen
since before the COVID 19 pandemic.
The consumer price index,
which is the benchmark
measure of inflation
rose 0.9% in June.
The largest one month increase since 2008.
Vacation related expenses weren't spared.
Prices increased for everything
from new cameras and swimsuits
to rental cars and hotel rooms.
- We're just, have this
kind of collective need
to get out and about.
- [announcer] Experts say price increases
reflect an economy on the
upswing from pandemic lows.
But higher demand has made
some vacation essentials
harder to come by.
Here's why that is, in some strategies
to help avoid the sticker shock.
As lockdowns have eased,
summer holiday travel has
surged both in the air
and on the ground.
AAA says more than 47
million people traveled
over the 4th of July holiday weekend,
which is 40% more than last year.
But US Air travel is still recovering
after the pandemic drove
it to a virtual standstill.
Much of the recovery lag has
to do with the slow return
of business travel.
However, airlines prepared
for an almost normal schedule
of flights this summer
as leisure travel demand returned.
Contributing to airfare
increasing nearly 25%
since last year.
If you're looking for cheaper airfare,
"WSJ" Travel Editor, Deborah Dunn
suggest switching up when you fly.
- The key to finding
less expensive airfare,
is to be really flexible.
Not just traveling on a weekend
or traveling from a Saturday to Sunday,
but I would look at the price difference
if you fly on a Tuesday or Wednesday.
- [announcer] But once
you're all booked in
and touchdown at your destination,
you still may hit those higher prices.
Vehicle rental prices are
up over 87% from a year ago.
The simple reason is that
rental companies have less cars.
Smaller rental fleets had one big issue.
Summer demand surged
over 300% in some cities,
according to KAYAK.
This has led some
travelers being turned away
at the rental counter because
there aren't enough cars
on the lot.
And with a semiconductor shortage,
continuing to hamper new car production,
some analysts think it
will be well into 2022
before fleet supplies are
enough to meet demand.
- Book months and months ahead.
And I wouldn't book a
non-refundable reservation.
The other possibility is to
look at picking up a car in town
rather than in the airport,
you'll have to take an
Uber from the airport,
but it's still day to day,
probably a better deal.
- [narrator] Those with
their own set of wheels
could count themselves lucky
if they weren't facing the
steepest gasoline prices
in nearly seven years
as gas shortages have
plagued many regions.
The Colonial Pipeline cyber attack in May
led to East Coast shortages
right before the summer season.
And some regions of the
country have had a hard time
restocking gas stations because
of a lack of truck drivers.
Many of whom had been laid
off during the pandemic,
according to analysts.
And the high prices, aren't
restricted to travel expenses.
Men's and women's swimwear prices were up
1.4 and 5.5% respectively,
which analysts attribute
to pent-up vacation demand.
Demand outpacing supply
has hit other vacation essentials as well.
Like cameras, which have
risen in price by almost 6%.
And depending on where
your head hits the pillow,
you could be paying
more for accommodations.
Room rates have recovered
to pre pandemic levels.
But the slow return of business travel
has kept occupancy rates slightly lower
than before the pandemic
according to analysts.
And while demand may be high
in traditional destinations
like Florida and Hawaii,
experts say price
increases are being driven
by vacationers booking
bigger accommodations
that may be off the beaten path.
Travelers are opting
for larger hotel suites
or entire rental houses
to accommodate families
vacationing together.
And according to AirDNA,
which tracks short-term rental
prices of Airbnb and Vrbo,
demand in small cities in
rural locations has surged
over 51% since 2019.
The current vacation
season is being defined
by an economy in recovery
and a population desperate for some RnR,
even if it puts a dent in their wallets.
- Be flexible about where you're gonna go,
when you're gonna go, how
long you're gonna stay.
Flexibility, I think is the
operative word this summer.
The last thing you wanna be
is stressed out on vacation.
- But if prices continue to rise,
a stress-free vacation
may be harder to come by.
(gentle music)